the number i want to talk about now is
the square root of two my favorite fact
about root two well if you take
the a series of paper so this is a4
paper it's pretty standard in most of
the world if you take a piece of paper
like this if you look at the ratio
between the long edge and the short edge
which means if you measure the long edge
and you divide by the short edge it will
be the square root of two and they pick
this on purpose
the square root of two is about 1.41
something or other and it's the number
you get if you work with pythagoras
theorem which said that if you have a
unit length along there and a unit
length along there so this length the
square of this length plus the square of
that is that this length is root two
it's a square root of two if i fold this
piece of paper in half let's try that
out
this now
is something called a5 paper we started
with a4 this is now a5 paper if you do
the same thing again if you take the
long edge of this and divide by the
short edge it will again be the square
root of two the ratio is the same they
do this so that you can scale things up
and scale them down without it being
disproportionate square root of two is
this which is
1.41 it runs on forever it doesn't stop
at a particular point and there are a
whole range of these this is just the
first of many another one is pi
in fact they start off with a zero and a
zero is defined to be a piece of paper
which has ratio square root of 2 and it
has an area of 1 meter squared in fact
root 2 is the only ratio where this
works and i'm going to show that it's
the only ratio this works there you go
with our rectangular piece of paper this
is your long edge which i'm going to
call a
and this is your short edge which i'm
going to call b
now if i take the long edge a and divide
by the short edge b i get a ratio it's
actually going to be root two but let's
pretend we don't know that yet
but this is what i want if i cut this in
half
i want this now to be the longer edge so
b
is now the long edge the short edge
is actually half of a it's this side
half of a
now i want that to be the same ratio as
i had before in other words i want these
two things
to be equal so all you have to do now is
rearrange this play with this a little
let's see what we get okay let's take
the b's over this side the a's over this
side if you play with it
you'll get a squared on the left and 2
b squared on the right hand side or in
other words
a squared divided by b squared
equals 2
or
square root it square root both sides
and you'll get a divided by b
on the left
and on the right you get the square root
of two and this
was actually the ratio we wanted to find
the only ratio where this works is the
square root of two
this is pythagoras's theorem
pythagoreans were a cult
way way back and they might have been a
figure called pythagoras associated with
this but they were a very strange bunch
and they believed
in this theorem they believed in the
harmony of natural numbers so if you
want to do music you took a bit of
string a certain tension if you took
half the length you get an harmonious
note with it
they thought all of nature was composed
of
numbers they thought that everything
could either be expressed as a pure
integer or a ratio of integers that was
their fundamental core belief what did
they know they had the numbers one two
three four five uh they had worked out
the fractions that you can divide two
things together you know three fifths
one half that sort of thing they had
other beliefs as well that you shouldn't
marry a woman who wore gold jewelry for
for example or you should be a
vegetarian and you shouldn't eat fava
beans and you shouldn't urinate towards
the sun
there was
a disciple of this strange set called he
passes
and he worked out that if you had
believed in
this theorem pythagoras's theorem
then you could show mathematically
a proof showing that this number
is not a ratio of two integers
but a number that could not be written
as a fraction that was a new thing
uh that went on forever that's what an
irrational number is and they dislike
this so much
i can't begin to tell you how much they
disliked it so they took him out to sea
according to legend
and he didn't come back somehow either
they drowned him or left him on a
deserted island he wasn't seen again
they did apparently they suppressed
this information they weren't sure that
this was a real thing we call them now
irrational numbers because they don't
fit in with this pythagorean viewpoint
it's the same sort of problem that
people have today
people say to me oh i've heard of
complex numbers i've heard of that
i don't believe they exist i don't i
don't understand it
same problem they do exist it's just you
have to get used to it
so he was one of the first people to be
persecuted for proving people wrong with
their previous ideas and this has gone
on through history i mean i could tell
you about
physicists who've suffered like bruno
giudano who went to
burnt at the stake for saying the
universe was infinite and the catholic
church said well that doesn't leave any
room for god
we're going to prove that root two
is irrational it cannot be written as a
fraction the way we prove this is a
really powerful useful mathematical
proof called contradiction we're going
to assume the opposite i'm going to
assume you can write it as a fraction
let's assume we can write it as a
divided by b
and this a and b are special they are
integers they're whole numbers okay
they're one two three four five there's
something like that
and then it's in its smallest possible
terms
so
we're not including things like
two divided by four
because that's that's a half that's not
in its smallest possible terms all right
let's see what we can do if you come up
with an idea
which is right
but goes against conventional wisdom you
can be
sent to a desert island or burnt at the
stake or executed because people don't
like their ideas about how the world
should be upset even if you can disprove
it it's not a good idea to urinate
towards the sun
i'm going to square
both sides
so on the left hand side i get a 2
on the right hand side i get a squared
divided by b squared this time a and b
are whole numbers remember
let's play with it we get 2b squared on
the left
equals a squared on the right now what
i've shown here is i've shown that a
squared is even
because it's a multiple of two
it's an even number
and you can show that because a squared
is even
a is even as well
well if it was two odd numbers squared
that would be an odd number so yeah yeah
if a squared is even the original number
a that was even so
a
is
even
okay
so a is even
let's call it um something else call it
a equals two times
c
okay
so what do we have now
two b squared on the left-hand side
is 2 times c because it's even squared
this is equal to 4
c squared
in other words i'm saying b squared is
equal to c squared can you see that b
squared is even
if b squared is even like before
b
is
even
what i've shown
is a is even and b is even
that's a problem
they can't both be even like my example
of two divided by four it's not in its
smallest possible terms if they're both
even so this
is an impossible fraction it doesn't
exist you cannot write root two as a
fraction like this